carole on devrait être remercié déjà
d'être là kelly nous a raconté son rêve
alors vous avez rêvé voulais raconter
j'ai rêvé que nous l émission sur une
grande patinoire et que cyril et moi on
dansait comme de grands patineurs
artistiques des moindres le gore et
honda ont dansé tous et puis si
l'élément est au milieu comme ça et puis
on faisait des pirouettes
il ya plusieurs significations alors la
première déjà c'est que il ya une forme
d'ambition
en fait chez vous à balai peut paraître
un peu agressive donc on peut dire que
peut-être qu'inconsciemment vous rêvez
d'abord vous d'avoir votre propre
émission ou en tout cas peut-être de
prendre sa place et je ressens comme ça
moi aussi pour ça que nous avons
heureusement on le rappelle c'est un
rêve et il ya aussi si possible et une
explication peut-être sexuelle oui
inconsciemment il va falloir une forme
de séduction ou dans l'analyse de
frustration en fait par rapport à une
envie sexuelle avec la première fois la
première nation à veux prendre ma place
je sais qu'on ne maîtrise pas en fait
ah bin là jolie ballade basse mais
battant mitraillé ça va être vite fesses
par terre on a de toute façon plein de
frustration sexuelle c'est le regard
pour ça qu on arrive à les retenir
aucune avec vous d'ailleurs sexuellement
[Rires]
mais c'est vrai en fait je faisais des
mots avec ma femme d'à cyril nous nous
regarder il décide d'essayer de
rattraper zizi mais le trouvais pas
puisqu'il en a pas
[Rires]
celle de cris tout comme ça
[Applaudissements]
je trouve pas ici c'est surtout que à
mon avis vous avez dû être ensemble
thoune ou non un moment donné dans
jamais été inclus tout nu les japonais
un petit peu on en a connu dans le dans
le sauna rappelez-vous oui alors c'est
dans ces cas là c'est tous les deux
jours alors c'est peut-être ça voilà il
ya une peut-être une meilleure dans le
jacuzzi vous tout avait fondu